dans le fils in de bertrand vaut le
manque d' espaces se fait cruellement
sentir
car depuis que ce pharmacien s'est lancé
dans la vente de produits
pharmaceutiques en ligne les commandes
affluent en moyenne une centaine par
jour
ainsi il ne regrette pas de s'être lancé
dans l'aventuré
ça nous a permis surtout d'avoir de
nouveaux clients qui se situe partout
dans le monde partout en france mais
également dans des pays très éloignés on
envoie des commandes au japon en
australie au brésil
et ça c'est des clients que nous
n'aurions jamais eu à tournus et donc on
a pu développer de nouveaux secteurs et
aujourd'hui grâce à internet j'ai créé
cinq postes dans les personnes recrutées
se trouve un webmaster qui élu domicile
dans la pharmacie
il fait vivre le site et met en ligne
les produits tout en travaillant sur le
fluence des moteurs de recherche
le plus important c'est de savoir bien
sortir sur les premières pages et ses
terrasses et là dessus on va être entre
les personnes et tout le monde n'est pas
bon référencement c'est pour ça que nous
on ne sorte pas sur google un système
robotique a même été mis en place pour
aider à préparer plus rapidement les
commandes sans se tromper et côté tarifs
entre l'officine traditionnel et le site
internet on peut noter des différences
de prix c'est souvent moins chers sur le
web nous derrière le travail est déjà
mâché
il ya pas de conseils il n'ya pas de
temps passé avec le client c'est
beaucoup plus rapide et sur internet les
commandes sont plus importantes
en moyenne elles sont cinq fois plus
importante qu'une vente ici à la
pharmacie donc ça nous permet de réduire
les coûts en étant plus efficace
il ya quand même un bémol la faim sont
plus chers sur internet les produits
lourds parce qu'ils sont coûteux expédié
en bourgogne celui pharmacies sont
autorisés à vendre leurs produits sur
internet
alors pour éviter les contrefaçons de
médicaments la chambre syndicale des
pharmaciens de saône et loire lance un
appel on engage chaque internaute à
aller vérifier l'authenticité du site
lorsqu'ils vont acheter un médicament
sur internet sur le site de l'ordre des
pharmaciens vous avez la possibilité de
voir les pharmacies qui sont autorisés
répertoriés enfin sachez que les
médicaments soumis à une ordonnance ne
sont pas commandable sur internet
ton